hey youtubers it's Charlie and if you
did not see the awesome news John Wesley
Shipp the original flash just got cast
on the new show and Stephen Amell just
said that a whole bunch of those
characters are coming on arrow someone
is also getting a shiny new superhero
suit before the arrow finale this year -
everybody high-five each other all right
so let's do a quick breakdown of all
that news starting with the arrow stuff
so Stephen Amell said that Central City
characters are coming to arrow this
season
that's characters plural meaning Grant
Gustin and at least one other person
will be coming he also said that the
characters would bounce back and forth
next season at least in cameos the
probably do special episodes like the
mid-season finale when Grant Gustin
debuted as Barry Allen you know like
many team-ups many Justice League
episodes if you will no idea who that
other flash character will be you know
the one that's coming to arrow before
the end of the season but it's most
likely to be one of the other people
they've cast recently my bet is on iris
West just because it would add a really
nice triangle ship between Felicity
Barry and iris I can already see the
tumblr gifs in my mind it is going to be
ridiculous
in related arrow news there will also be
one more costume hero on the show before
the end of the season all signs are
pointing to Roy you know getting his
real deal red outfit I would bet on it
looking like a version of Oliver suit
previously I predicted he'd get the suit
after they defeated Slade but Stephen
Amell based on what he said is making it
sound like that will happen sooner so on
to flash news John Wesley Shipp has been
cast in a you know secret role so let's
try and guess who that is right now my
money is either on grant gustin's father
you know Barry Allen's father or you
know fingers crossed Jay Garrick it
sounds like it's gonna be a really
substantial role whatever it is so I'm
thinking he's going to be like the Moira
queen type person on the show like a
supporting character who's just really
important the main cast will still be
Grant Gustin iris West her father
detective West and Edward Thawne if he
is playing Barry Allen's father then
he's basically going to spend most of
season one in prison and I think that
his role is actually gonna be one that
allows him to be on screen more so I
don't think that's as likely the real
question is is why would they keep his
character a secret if it wasn't
something huge that's really where my
Jay Garrick speculation comes from
speaking of meta moments ship also
starred as Professor zoom on brave and
the bold
so he has played other versions of the
flash since that 1990 series no matter
who he turns out to be though I'm
getting super pumped Jeff Jones was not
kidding they're going all-out for this
series the important thing to remember
about all this is that they have not
started filming that pilot yet and it
has to be given a serious order before
it actually turns into a TV show
worst case scenario everything falls
through you can still breathe easy
because Grant Gustin and all these other
characters they cast will still be a
part of arrow so we will get flashed no
matter what they will keep those
characters inside the CW universe so we
will see them again no matter what my
two big questions for you guys though is
one who do you think John Wesley Shipp
is playing you know is it Jay Garrick or
is it some other character and - do you
think that Roy will get that costume
before the end of the season since the
pilot starts filming in March they're
gonna continue to make casting
announcements and hopefully we'll find
out stuff from the set so be sure to
subscribe to get all my videos I'll be
doing a lot more regular bonus flash
videos as we move forward next week will
be more bonus videos but I'll try to do
another flash bonus video to maybe like
my top 5 stories that they should adapt
for season 1 because there's a whole
bunch of stuff that could be doing right
now click here to get my top five
reasons why Loki is gonna be on agents
of shield this season and click here to
get my first preview for the flash TV
show thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys tonight high five